moi président de la république -
président de la république moi président
de la république
[Musique]
je vais jamais vu toi bon bah voilà
bon
[Musique]
on
il n'y a pas de confusion elle n'est pas
élue partiellement en corrèze et moi
partiellement dans les deux simples
chacun chez soi
[Musique]
si je ne faisais absolument rien la cour
des comptes je continuerai à gagner
quinze mille francs par mois
25000 si je faisais des rapports mai
sans forcément faire énormément je
pourrais d'oser mon travail rester chez
moi quand je suis fatiguée aller à la
cour des comptes dans mon bureau pour
passer des coups de téléphone bref je
serai totalement libre je serai un vrais
privilégiés comme je l'étais avant
d'être élu lui
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lui
face à la terreur la france doit être
forte
elle doit être grande et les autorités
de l'état ferme nous le serons j'ai
décidé de ne pas être candidat
l'élection
[Musique]